a no ser que vivas en una cueva y tu
único medio de información sea visual
político en cuyo caso gracias sigue así
te habrás enterado de que fidel castro
ha muerto y con él muere todo un icono
del comunismo que gobernó cuba con mano
de hierro durante más de 50 años muchos
se preguntan hoy si la muerte de fidel
castro- marcará un periodo de transición
en cuba entre lo que es una dictadura
comunista hacia una democracia de libre
mercado
pero lo cierto es que ya en el año 2008
fidel pasó al poder a su hermano pequeño
raúl castro como veis todo queda en casa
y lo cierto es que a raúl no le ha
quedado más remedio que aplicar una
serie de reformas que hace años serían
impensables en un régimen que presumía
de mantener puras las esencias del
comunismo tradicional
está claro que el castrismo al menos tal
y como lo conocemos es un sistema
agotado y no sabemos en qué se va a
convertir cuba pero sí sabemos que está
cambiando y todo esto dará mucho que
hablar a los medios de comunicación
durante los próximos meses pero nos
habéis pedido que hagamos un vídeo
especial hablando sobre cuba y como
sabéis en visual polític nos gusta
siempre darle una vuelta de tuerca a la
noticia porque hay una pregunta muy
importante que queda en el aire ha
llegado ya el momento de invertir en
cuba se puede ganar dinero gracias a los
cambios que se esperan en este país hoy
vamos a responder a esta pregunta
y la historia nos demuestra que cuando
un país pasa de una economía planificada
a una de libre mercado se abre una
ventana de oportunidad en la que es
posible hacer mucho dinero buena muestra
de ello es esta casa de la que os hablo
que los que seguís visual polític desde
hace tiempo
sabéis que está en praga república checa
el edificio entero en el que vivo es
propiedad de un italiano que lo compró a
principios de los años 90 y es que en
aquella época república checa- estaba
empezando a abrir su economía tras
varias décadas de comunismo eso
significa que por primera vez se podían
comprar y vender viviendas
pero no sólo eso como el país era
relativamente pobre el precio de las
casas era muy bajo y eso atrajo a un
montón de inversores extranjeros sobre
todo del norte de italia que compraron
bloques enteros de apartamentos a precio
de saldo
años más tarde la economía checa empezó
a crecer muy rápidamente llegaron a
empresas extranjeras turismo etcétera
así que en poco tiempo esos pisos
duplicaron su valor convirtiendo a sus
propietarios en millonarios algo muy
parecido podría ocurrir en cuba'
pero esperad un momento porque no es oro
todo lo que reluce otros países
excomunistas como ucrania no han corrido
la misma suerte y han arruinado a más de
un inversor y por eso es tan importante
entender la situación de cuba y el rumbo
de las reformas que están tomando pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de perspectiva
histórica
la situación de cuba hoy en día como os
decía cuba es un país comunista
eso significa que toda la economía está
controlada por el estado eso significa
que en su mejor momento el estado
empleaba al 92% de la población activa
es decir que prácticamente todo el mundo
trabajaba para el sector público esto
eran los años 80 cuando cuba exportaba
azúcar tabaco y todo tipo de frutas a la
unión soviética sin embargo en 1989 cae
el muro de berlín y cuba pierde a su
principal socio comercial
si eso le sumamos el embargo comercial
de eeuu que prohíbe a sus empresas hacer
cualquier tipo de negocios con la isla
tenemos que cuba estaba prácticamente
aislado en el mundo y eso se tradujo en
una crisis bestial que se prolongó hasta
el año 2000 año en el que hugo chávez se
hace con el poder en venezuela como ya
os contamos en este otro vídeo venezuela
era un país muy rico gracias a sus
inmensas reservas de petróleo y como
castro y chávez eran muy amigos uva
empezó a recibir millones de
petrodólares de venezuela'
y esto supuso todo un balón de oxígeno
para el régimen castrista sin embargo en
el año 2013 el precio del petróleo cae
en picado y venezuela se hunde y con
ella también se hunde cuba en este
momento fidel castro- ya se había
jubilado y raúl castro- era quien
llevaba las riendas del gobierno y raúl
se da cuenta de que está aislado en este
mundo y que si no cambia las cosas lo va
a pasar muy mal
las reformas chinas de raúl castro por
cierto que esto tan afrodisíaco que está
sonando es la música de ry un cantante
compositor y guitarrista de medellín en
colombia que nos ha enviado su música si
os gusta encontrareis el link a su canal
de youtube en los enlaces de la
descripción
las calles
en ese mismo año 2013 raúl castro
anunció una serie de reformas muy
significativas la primera es la
legalización de los llamados
cuentapropistas que son algo parecido a
los profesionales autónomos es decir que
por primera vez a los cubanos se les
permite tener pequeños negocios por
supuesto que con muchísimas
restricciones de entrada no pueden
contratar a nadie y sólo pueden trabajar
en una serie de sectores permitidos por
el estado sin embargo en sólo tres años
los cuentapropistas suponen ya el 10 por
ciento de la población activa cubana
existe el visito ese que si tú hacías
algo particular antes te lo quitaban sea
el llano o sea él ya estoy a eso
aburrido ya sea ahora el gobierno del
estado cubano tiene una plena confianza
en un cuentapropista porque es el futuro
pero esperad un momento porque hay mucho
más lo cierto es que raúl castro parece
estar imitando el modelo del partido
comunista chino del que por cierto
hablaremos la próxima semana de hecho
al más puro estilo den xiaoping raúl
castro ha creado también una zona
económica especial a la que ha llamado
el centro de desarrollo mariel y esto
qué significa pues que dentro de esta
zona pueden instalarse empresas
extranjeras contratar cubanos tener
beneficios y todo esto con muchísimas
menos restricciones que en el resto de
cuba' cinco empresas extranjeras dos
cubanas y una mixta son las primeras
ocho entidades presentes actualmente en
la zona especial de desarrollo de mariel
la cual se convertirá en el principal
polo económico de cuba y os preguntaréis
cómo es posible que hoteles barceló que
es una empresa española pueda estar
trabajando en cuba cuando supuestamente
está prohibida la entrada de empresas
extranjeras porque seguramente muchos de
los que estáis viendo este vídeo os
hayáis sido en algún momento de
vacaciones a la habana y os hayáis
hospedado en un hotel de la cadena meliá
hoteles barceló son cadenas de hoteles
españolas y que llevan operando en este
país desde el año 2000
pero lo cierto es que para poder
trabajar en cuba' tanto hoteles barceló
como hoteles media tuvo que hacer un
acuerdo de asociación con el gobierno
cubano es decir que los hoteles son
propiedad del estado y las empresas
simplemente se dedican a gestionar lo
explotarlo y llevarse parte de los
beneficios nada más es decir que hasta
ahora era imposible montar cualquier
negocio en cuba' a no ser que te
asociadas con el gobierno cubano sin
embargo la creación de esta zona
económica especial marcó una tendencia
muy clara y es lo mismo que hizo china
en los años 80 a esto hay que sumarle la
legalización de la compraventa de
viviendas en sólo dos años se han
vendido más de 40 mil casas en cuba' ojo
esto no significa que tengan propiedad
privada y por supuesto que todas estas
operaciones comerciales han tenido un
montón de restricciones pero no
olvidemos que aquí estamos hablando de
una tendencia
pero lo más importante de todo fue el
anuncio de obama de poner fin al embargo
comercial el problema
que todavía no se ha aprobado en el
congreso de los eeuu y que con donald
trump del presidente es muy difícil
predecir lo que va a pasar
una compañía controlada por donald trump
llevó a cabo negocios de forma secreta
en cuba durante la presidencia de fidel
castro a pesar de las estrictas
prohibiciones estadounidenses que hacen
estas prácticas ilegales
en cualquier caso si trump mantuviera el
bloqueo comercial a cuba no tendría por
qué ser una mala noticia al menos no
para los inversores latinoamericanos y
españoles porque si los estadounidenses
no pueden hacer negocios con cuba están
dejando vía libre para que entren todos
los demás
pero esperad un momento porque nada de
esto significa que cuba vaya a
convertirse en un paraíso de libertad
desde la noche a la mañana ni siquiera
que sea una buena oportunidad para
invertir dinero en realidad pueden darse
dos escenarios o bien cuba apuesta por
una transición al estilo de
checoslovaquia lo que ahora es república
checa o bien elige un modelo más
parecido al de ucrania vamos a ver ahora
estos dos modelos
checoslovaquia frente a ucrania en 1990
tanto república checa- como ucrania
abandonaron el comunismo pero con una
diferencia muy importante los
checoslovacos habían hecho toda una
revolución la revolución de terciopelo
para derrocar a su dictador y el nuevo
gobierno democrático dirigido por este
señor que veis aquí que se llamaba
vaclav hável mandó a casa a todos los
antiguos gerifaltes de la dictadura en
ucrania sin embargo mantuvieron a toda
su clase política y eso que en este caso
el país se acababa de independizar de la
unión soviética lo cierto es que es un
nuevo presidente leonid kravchuk venía
del mismísimo partido comunista
soviético así que era un cambio de
régimen pero con las mismas personas
pero esto no es todo porque tanto cuba
como ucrania como checoslovaquia eran
economías planificadas donde todas las
empresas pertenecían al estado así que
el primer paso para abrir la economía
consistía en privatizar las pero ojo
porque no todas las privatizaciones son
iguales
a él
los secos cogieron a todas sus empresas
hicieron un cálculo económico de su
valor y lo dividieron en pequeñas
participaciones ovales si tú eras un
ciudadano checo tenías el derecho a
comprar uno de estos vales a un precio
muy razonable
básicamente el equivalente a una semana
de tu sueldo de hecho el 80 por ciento
de los ciudadanos lo compró y con ese
papel en la mano tenías derecho a poder
participar en una subasta para comprar
acciones de las empresas checas incluso
si no sabías muy bien cómo hacerlo el
propio gobierno checo impulsó la
creación de fondos de inversión estos
fondos te podrían asesorar para que
pudieras invertir tu dinero de forma
inteligente y te decían pues te merece
la pena comprar equis acciones de esta
empresa o de esta otra
por supuesto que todo esto generó
muchísima corrupción pero también
consiguió que la mayoría de los
ciudadanos se beneficiarán de las
privatizaciones y además se terminaron
de hacer en muy poquitos años y la
prueba es que a día de hoy república
checa- es un país tan igualitario como
pueda serlo alemania y con un nivel de
vida comparable al de cualquier país
europeo
y el caso de ucrania es distinto es
verdad que también decidieron vender
participaciones ovales a sus ciudadanos
es decir que si tú eras un ucraniano
también podías comprar tu papelito que
te daba derecho a ir a una subasta para
comprar acciones de empresas ucranianas
pero el problema es que el gobierno
subastó muy poquitas empresas y las que
vendió fueron las menos importantes así
que la mayor parte de los ciudadanos
ucranianos estuvo durante años en su
casa con el papelito esperando a poder
cambiarlo por algo de valor mientras
tanto ucrania tenía una inflación
bestial así que estos vales que al
principio cuando se emitieron valían más
o menos unos mil quinientos dólares de
repente se vendían en el mercado negro
por menos de diez así que en cualquier
momento podía llegar el oligarca de
turno y decirte mira chico toma este
dinero dame tu participación que no te
va a servir de nada y justo en ese
momento en el que las participaciones de
las empresas estaban en manos de los
amigos del gobierno
sorpresa en ese momento sí que se
subastaban las empresas importantes
el resultado solo se privatizaron a
aquellas empresas que interesaban a los
gerifaltes del gobierno de hecho todavía
quedan muchísimas empresas públicas en
ucrania por privatizar pero lo más
importante es que el 85 por ciento de la
riqueza en ucrania está en manos de los
50 oligarcas más ricos eso significa
poca estabilidad política y un clima
horrendo para la inversión y todo esto
por no hablar de la guerra con rusia así
que si alguien compro viviendas en
quiebra hace 10 años ahora seguramente
se estará dando cabezazos contra la
pared
pero volvamos a cuba porque aquí tenemos
elementos parecidos a ucrania y
elementos parecidos a checoslovaquia por
un lado cuba está controlada
prácticamente en su totalidad por una
familia los castro que no van a dejar el
poder fácilmente tampoco parece que
exista ninguna figura carismática como
un vaclav hável en checoslovaquia
alguien que tenga el suficiente apoyo
social como para poder sustituir a la
élite política dominante pero por el
otro lado cuba tiene una diáspora muy
grande y muy influyente solo en eeuu hay
más de 2 millones de cubanos que suponen
el 20 por ciento de la población de cuba
y estos cubanos han recibido una
educación democrática tienen mucha
influencia política y podrían ayudar a
construir unas instituciones fuertes y
democráticas en la habana
si esto fuera así cuba podría
convertirse en ese estado de derecho con
buenas oportunidades para la inversión y
que además ayudaría a los cubanos a
salir de la pobreza
y la pregunta es si creéis que va a
pasar terminará cuba pareciéndose más a
ucrania la república checa- podéis
dejarme la respuesta en los comentarios
y no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones como siempre si alguien
quiere profundizar más en este tema
encontrará varios links en la
descripción que os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto